الخارجيه السعوديه تعلن بدء محادثات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تستمر
عده ايام من اجل هدنه انسانيه
روسيا تشن وحمله غارات واسعه على اوكرانيا
عشيه احتفالات يوم النصر التاسع من مايو
ترحيب الروسي وتحفظ امريكيه على عوده
مشروطه لسوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل الخير واهلا بكم الى
فتره اخباريه جديده من العربيه نبداها
بهذه النشره اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه في
بيان ان ممثلين من الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع بداوا يوم امس محادثات تمهيديه في
جده وان هذه المحادثات ستستمر لايام حتى
الوصول الى وقف فعال ودائم لاطلاق النار
الخارجيه السعوديه اكدت في بيانها ان
السودان يمر بازمه غير مسبوقه وان الخيار
الوحيد هو الوقوف الى جانبه
بينما تعمل الوسطات الدوليه والاقليميه
على التهدئه السياسيه بين طرفين نزاع في
السودان تعكس المجريات على الارض صوره
مختلفه فالقتال في السودان ما زال مستمرا
رغم الهدنه الطويله لتسمع اصوات
الاشتباكات جنوب ووسط العاصمه الخرطوم
بالاخص في منطقه السوق العروي ومحيط
المطار وافاد شهود عيان بتحليق طائرات
حربيه وسماع يدوي انفجار قوي واصوات اسلحه
ثقيله في محيط القصر الرئاسي والقياده
العامه للجيش كما شنت الطائرات ضربات جويه
في حي الرياض بالخرطوم لم ينحصر استمرار
الصراع في تلك المنطقه بل سمع دوي
انفجارات وتحليق للطيران الحربي في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري واشتباكات متفرقه في منطقتي
كافوري وشرق النيل بالاضافه لاصوات مضادات
الطيران في اندرمان
اتهامات متبادله بين الطرفين النزاع بخرق
الهدنه فالجيش السوداني اتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بارسال تعزيزات للخرطوم بينما اكدت
الجهه الاخرى شن غارات من قبل الجيش
السوداني على مناطق لقوات الدعم السريع
والتي بدورها حاولت استهداف قياده قوات
الدفاع الجوي
وفي ظل الاشتباكات المستمره فتح الباب
امام عمليات النهب والحرق على وجه الخصوص
في المنطقه الصناعيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
وضع يعكس تصريحات طرفي الصراع باستعدادهما
لمناقشه الهدنه والوضع الانساني دون
الالتزام بوقف النهائي لاطلاق النار وعمر
العربيه
استقبل ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان مساء الاحد مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي
وتم خلال اللقاء استعراض العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين وسبل تعزيزها في
مختلف المجالات كما تم استعراض مسجلات
الاوضاع الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام
المشترك كما استقبل ولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان نائبه حاكم ابوظبي مستشار الامن
الوطني في دوله الامارات ومستشار الامن
القومي الهندي وتم بعثه سبل تعزيز
العلاقات والروابط بين دولهم وبما يعزز
النمو والاستقرار في المنطقه
وجه العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان وجه مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
بتقديم مساعدات انسانيه متنوعه بقيمه 100
مليون دولار لصالح الشعب السوداني كما وجه
الملك سلمان والامير محمد بن سلمان بتنظيم
حمله شعبيه عبر منصه ساهم وذلك لتخفيف
اثار الاوضاع التي يمر بها الشعب السوداني
حاليا
المساعدات سوف تركز في هذه المرحله على
الاولويات في الاحتياج الانساني
وستكون في القطاعات من اهم قطاع المساعدات
الطبيه وليس سوف تعمل على سد الاحتياجات
في المستشفيات التي تقدم الخدمات لعلاج
حول المصابين كذلك سوف تكون هناك مساعدات
غذائيه تشمل سينار غذائيه معياريه وزنها
70 كيلو جرام تكفي لاسره مكونه من سبعه
اشخاص لمده شهر كامل هذه المساعدات
الغذائيه سوف تغطي مناطق الاحتياج في جميع
ولايات السودان كذلك باذن الله عز وجل هذه
المساعدات الغلايه السادس
مناطق النزوح واحتياجات النازحين
والتضررين وتخفيف على الموارد وكذلك
المجتمعات المضيفه كذلك المساعدات سوف
تشمل باذن الله عز وجل
المساعدات الايوائيه من ناحيه توفير كل ما
يحتاجه قطاع اللواء من خيام او حق ائب
وغيرها
والى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا قال رئيس
بلديه
انها خمسه اشخاص على الاقل اصيبوا في
ضربات وصيه على المدينه فالوقت الذي شنت
فيه موسكو هجوما اخر واسع النطاق على
اوكرانيا واوضحت التشيكو ان ثلاثه اشخاص
اصيبوا في انفجارات في منطقه سلومينيسكا
بالمدينه واصيب اثنان اخرون عندما سقط
حطام طائره مسيره على منطقه سفيوتيشين
وتقع المنطقتان الى الغرب من وسط العاصمه
قال قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الاوكزندر ان روسيا كثافه من حده القصف
على بخمود بالاسلحه الثقيله واضاف سلسيكا
عبر صفحته على تطبيق تيليجرام ان الجيش
الروسي بدا في استخدام معدات اكثر تقدما
في الوقت الذي يحاول فيه تجميع المزيد من
الوحدات حول المدينه وفسر قائد القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه تحركات الروس بسعيهم
للسيطره على المدينه قبل احتفالات عيد
النصر في روسيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من جانبه يا حضر الرئيس التشيكي في
القياده الاوكرانيه من كارثه الهجوم
المضاده المتسارع وقلب ان هناك اعترافا
بان الفجوات لا تزال قائمه في قدره
اوكرانيا على البقاء لتصعيد هجوم الناجح
ضد القوات الروسيه واضاف رئيس تشيك ان
اوكرانيا ستواجه حتما خسائر فادحه بغض
النظر عن قوه قوتها ولا يمكنها تحمل فشل
الهجوم لانه يتطلب الكثير من حيث تجميع
معدات الافراد
ولوجيسيات الذخيره
توالت الردود العربيه والدوليه عقب
الاعلان الذي اتخذته جامعه الدول العربيه
باستعاده سوريا عضويتها واستئناف مشاركتها
في اجتماعات مجلس الجامعه وفور اعلان
الجامعه بينها باذره روسيا باعلان ترحيبها
وقالت ان قرار عوده سوريا الى الحضن
العربي سيسهم في تحسين الاجواء في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه في
بيان لها انها تتوقع من الدول العربيه
زياده دعمها لدمشق في اعاده الاعمار بعد
الصراع الترحيب الروسي قابله تحفظ امريكي
حيث اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه انها تتفهم
سعي الشركاء للتواصل المباشر مع الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد لمزيد من الضغط لحل
الازمه السوريه وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه
في بيان لها انها تشكك برغبه بشار الاسد
بحل الازمه في سوريا لكنها تتفق مع الشرك
العرب حول الاهداف النهائيه مشيره الى ان
عوده سوريا الى الجامعه قد تكون مبكره
وذلك قبول عوده سوريا الى مقعدها في
الجامعه كان قبولا مشروطا حيث اعلن الامين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو
الغيط ان قرار اعاده سوريا لا يعني اعاده
الدول العربيه لعلاقتها مع سوريا ولفت ابو
الغيط الى ان هذا القرار هو قرار سيادي
تتخذه كل دوله
فعوده سوريا هي بدايه للطريق وليس نهايه
للمسار بهذه الكلمات لخص امينو عام جامعه
الدول العربيه اهم قرارات مجلس الوزراء
الخارجيه العرب الذي اجتمع لمناقشه ملفات
سوريا والسودان وفلسطين وخلص الى تشكيل
لجنتي اتصال تضمان الجامعه والرياض
والقاهره لمواصله حلحله الامور
مصر بصفتها رئيس الجلسه اشارت الى مسؤوليه
الجميع عن تقدم المسار السوري في اطار
شروط وضعت في كل من جده وعمان تتعلق
بالعوده الامنه للاجئين وخطر الارهاب وضبط
الحدود لمنع تهريب المخدرات وغيرها ضروره
التفاعل الايجابي مع كل المكونات سواء
كانت سياسيه او انسانيه
وقضايا اخرى
ذات تاثير على المحيط الاقليمي وقضيه
تواجد القوات الاجنبيه دول مؤيده لقرار
عوده سوريا ابد ت رضاها وان كان الجميع
يعلم انه مسار ليس بالسهل يجب ان نكون
واقعين مساله سوريه مساله معقده صحيح
مساله الى علاقه بالسياده السوريه وداخل
السوري ولكن
في الساحه السوريه الان هناك
دول مختلفه
مصالحها متداخله ومؤثره ايضا في ساحه
السوريه ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سيادي لكل دوله على حده
السودان خرج بما جاء من اجله لناحيه تاكيد
وزراء الخارجيه على سيادته ووحده اراضيه
والتعامل مع الازمه الحاليه باعتبارها
شانا داخليا نسمي القرارات التي اصدارها
الميس الوزاري جامعه الدول العربيه اليوم
حيث اكدت على سياده السودان ووحدته وسلامه
اراضيه
وعدم التدخل في شؤون الداخليه عدد سوريا
الى الحاضنه العربيه مره اخرى وسواء كانت
ستسجل حضورا في قمه الرياض القادمه من
عدمه فان الامر الان منوط بدمشق كي تحقق
شروط التي وضعتها لها الدول العربيه
لتيسير قرار العوده تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره
اما بشاني عوده العلاقات الى طبيعتها
السابقه قال عمر
رحمون المتحدث باسم المصالحه السوريه ان
علاقات سوريا مع الاشقاء العرب لم تنقطع
ولم يتبقى سوى تتويج هذه العلاقات نحن في
سوريا على الانسان المسؤولين اكدوا اكثر
من مره بان العلاقات العربيه الثنائيه هي
اهم من العوده الى جامعه الدول العربيه
وبالتالي كان هناك عمل نشيط بين سوريا
وبين الدول وفي الحقيقه العلاقات الثنائيه
لم تبقى منقطعه الا ما عدد قليل جدا مع
هذه الدول مثل قطر والمغرب اما بقيه الدول
العربيه السفارات السوريه مفتوحه
مفتوحه في الدول العربيه وسفارات الدول
العربيه مفتوحه في سوريا
وقال المتحدث باسم المصالحه السوريه عمر
رحمون ايضا في لقائه مع العربيه ان عوده
سوريا للجامعه العربيه الخبر الابرز
والاهم عربيا واشار رحمون الى انه حتى
الان لا توجد اي اشاره الى حضور الرئيس
الاسد القمه او من ينوب عنهم مؤكدا بان
الامر يعود بذلك الى القياده السوريه طبعا
هذا خبر جيد اليوم عوده سوريا لمقعدها في
الجامعه العربيه وهو الخبر الابرز والاهم
عربيا عوده سوريا لمقعدها وفتح العرب
بابهم لسوريا اما موضوع حضور السيد الرئيس
القمه هذا طعام برسم القياده السوريه حتى
الان هذا شيء لم يتم التصريح عنه بامكان
الدوله ان يعني ان يحضر السيد الرئيس او
ان ينيب وزير خارجيته هذا برسم الدوله
السوريه حتى الان لا يوجد اي اشاره على
حضور السيد الرئيس او حضور من يونيب عنه
اذا اراد ان يجيب عن وزير الخارجيه او حتى
نائب الرئيس
اردوغان يوجه رساله تحذير اللهجه للمعارضه
بعد نجاحه في حشد اكبر تجمع انتخابي
لتاييده
اهلا بكم من جديد قبل اسبوع واحد من
الانتخابات الحاسمه في تركيا استطاع
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان حشد عشره الالاف
اسطنبول باكبر تجمع انتخابي تشهد البلاد
وذلك بعد يوم واحد فقط من تجمع المعارضه
الكبير في اسطنبول ايضا حيث يسعى كل من
المرشحين لاقناع الفئه المتردده بالتصويت
لهما
سيرا على الاقدام او في الحافلات او
بسياراتهم الخاصه مئات الالاف من سكان
اسطنبول والولايات المجاوره
استجابوا لدعوه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
للحضور الى مطار اتاتورك والمشاركه في
اكبر تجمع انتخابي تشهده البلاد
عشرات الالاف حضروا تجمع اردوغان الذي
اراد توجيهه عده رسائل للمعارضه ومنها انه
مازال لا يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره في الشارع
خصوصا في اكبر مدن البلاد اسطنبول
نحن نحب رئيسنا وسندعمه يوم الاحد القادم
وسيظهر للعالم كله ولترى ميرال اكشنار
وكليتشار اوغلو هذه الحشود
لاستقرار تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ولما حدث
في الفتره الاخيره من تقدم سننتخبه ونحن
مع تحالف الشعب وسندعمه
نحن هنا لندعم رئيسنا مقابل تحالف الامه
الذين حبسوا اربكان واسقطوا الحكومه في
الماضي
اردوغان لم يفوت فرصه الاشاره الى تسجيلات
تخص منافسه كمالك الجدار اوغلو زعيم
المعارضه ومرشح الطاوله السداسيه للرئاسه
حيث يتهم الرئيس خصمه بانه نسق مع حزب
العمال الكردستاني وتنظيم جولن وقوى غربيه
في سبيل وصوله للرئاسه
امريكا
سيد كمال هيا اعلن عن الاشخاص الذين
التقيت معهم في محطه الوقود وفي المطعم
خلال زيارتك الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
قبل اسبوع واحد فقط من الانتخابات الحاسمه
ما زالت هناك فئه متردده ويامل اردوغان في
كسب اصواتها من خلالها كذا حشود
في الانتخابات هذا العدد من الحشود اذا
اردنا مقارنتها مع تجمعات المعارضه فانها
لا تصل الى مستوى تجمعات رئيس الجمهوريه
وهذا سينعكس على صناديق الاقتراع
الائتلاف الحاكم بقياده حزب العداله
والتنميه الذي خسر مدينه اسطنبول في اخر
انتخابات محليه اراد اظهار قوته في هذه
المدينه على وجه التحديد بعد يوم واحد فقط
من اكبر تجمع للمعارضه في نفس المدينه
لكنه لم يكن بحجم التجمع الانتخابي
للائتلاف الحاكم في استمرار لحرب الساحات
والميادين بين المعسكرين
ستغري هذه الحشود الناخبين المترددين
بالتصويت له سؤال مرهون بالناخب وخياراته
في الرابعه عشر من مايو زيدان زنجلو
العربيه اسطنبول
بعد مروره سته اشهر على تشكيلها تمكنت
حكومه السودان خلالها من تخطي عدد من
العقبات السياسيه والامنيه والاقتصاديه
لكنها ما تزال تواجه تحديات تتعلق
بالاتفاق السياسي الذي انتجها
سته اشهر من عمر حكومه السودان التي جاءت
بعد مخاض عسير تمثل بصدام مسلح وانقسام
حاد داخل البيت الشيعي فتره تتلخص بمجموعه
من النجاحات والوعود التي لم تتحقق على
المستوى السياسي
والاقتصادي والخدمي
سياسيا يحسب للسوداني نجاحه في مسك العصا
من الوسط مع قيادات تحالف اداره الدوله
حتى الساعه على الرغم من وجود الخلافات
التي لا يحسب لها وزن في الحكومات
الائتلافيه الخلاف النفطي والمالي بين
اربيل وبغداد تم حله ولو بشكل مؤقت
ليس فقط على حل المشاكل وانما على البدء
من جديد بتطبيق واقع شراكه حقيقيه هدفه
بناء العراق بكل مناطقه من زاخو الى الفاو
وتقدم بخطوات واعتقد هذا شيء ايجابي جدا
ومساله الاتفاق النفط الاخير كان واضح لحل
اغلب المشاكل النفطيه بين بغداد لحين
تشريع قانون النفط والغاز
اعاده النازحين الى مناطقهم في جرف الصخر
وغيرها من بين الملفات التي تعهد السودان
بحلها امام القوى السنيه يضاف اليها تمرير
قانون العفو العام في البرلمان لم يتمكن
السوداني من تنفيذها الى الان الرئيس
الوزراء هو يكاد يكون ملزم بالاتفاق الذي
وقع ما بين الكتل السياسيه فيما يخص
موضوعات العفو العام بالنسبه
للاتفاق الذي جرى بين القوى السياسيه قبل
تشكيل الحكومه
اما شعبيا فكانت علاماته رضا والامل باديه
على وجوه العراقيين الذين ينتظرون المزيد
من حكومه السودان اقتصاديا خلوه يشتغل
على الخدمات الخدمات افضل يعني اكو تحسن
زين بالعمل هذا موجود وملموس يعني بالنسبه
للشارع العراقي حكومه السوداني تريد تختصر
المسافه الزمنيه اللي صار لها 20 سنه بدون
خدمات الى خدمات سريعه جدا
بس يريد نلمسه بعد عن طريق الواقع وين
يحتاج له وقت
تقديم الخدمات وضبط سعر صرف الدولار نسبيا
واستمرار الانفتاح على المحيط العربي
والدولي عوامل ايجابيه لنجاح حكومه
السودان لكن الاختبار الحقيقي لها يتمثل
بالتعديل الوزاري المرتقب والذي سيشمل
ثلاثه حقائب لم يتم الكشف عن اسمائها بعد
من بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه
اعتبر الملياردير الامريكي خلال الاجتماع
السنوي للمساهمين بمجموعته ان طريقه تعامل
الحكومه الامريكيه مع ازمه المصارف
الاقليميه كان ضعيفا مشيرا الى عدم عوده
الثقه بين المذيعين الى هذا الحد وتعرضت
العديد من البنوك المتوسطه الحجم في وول
ستريت الى هزات وتحديدا عن حينما عصفت
الازمه منذ بدايه شهر مارس باربعه بنوك
اقليميه في الولايات المتحده وجرى
الاستحواذ على ثلاثه منها لاحقا من قبل
مؤسسات اخرى وبمساعده السلطات
تواجه الحكومه الصينيه التي حاولت على
مدار السنوات الماضيه تدارك انخفاض معدلات
الانجاب في البلاد من خلال تقديم حوافز
مغريه لشعبها في ظل ازمه خانقه ونقص في
اليد العامله خصوصا في مجال التصنيع
بحث عن العماله دون جدوى واقع تعيشه عده
شركات صينيه التي تواجه اسوا نقص في اليد
العامله منذ عقود في بلد لطالما عرف
بتشدده حيال استقبال المهاجرين واستقدام
العمال الاجانب الصين التي حافظت على لقب
البلد الاكثر كثافه بالسكان في العالم
طوال 60 عاما تواجه اليوم اسوا ازمه في
سوق العمل بسبب التراجع الملحوظ في معدلات
الانجاب
ويعزز هذا الاضطراب في سوق العمل الصيني
تنامي المخاوف من ارتفاع وتيره التضخم في
الدوله الصناعيه القويه التي بلغت تعدادها
السكاني مليارا
و44 مليون نسمه فالبلاد ستواجه مشكله
كبيره في ملء ما يقرب من 30 مليون وظيفه
في مجال التصنيع بحلول عام 2025
في ظل رفض اللجوء الى خيار الهجره خصوصا
وان الحكومه الصينيه لا تبذل جهودا لجذب
المهاجرين من الخارج بل وتفرض على كل
متقدم استثمار 500 الف دولار في شركه
صينيه لمده ثلاث سنوات متتاليه وفق
مراقبينا سيؤثروا هذا الانخفاض على
الاقتصاد الصيني لاسباب كثيره ابرزها
ارتفاع عدد المسنين الذين سيشكلون عبئا
ماليا على الحكومه وانخفاض عدد القوه
العامله الشابه التي ستصبح مكلفه ما سيؤدي
لنقل بعض الصناعات من الصين لدول تتمتع
بوفره العماله ففي عام 2021 بلغ عدد
المواليد الجدد في الصين حوالي 480 الف
طفل وهو عدد قليل مقارنه بالمواليد التي
كانت قبل عشر سنوات حيث بلغ حوالي ثمانيه
ملايين طفل في عام 2011 ومن المتوقع ان
تنخفض معدلات الخصوبه في الصين بحلول عام
2030 بسبب اعتياد الصينيين على الاسر
الصغيره وارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه
في ختام هذه النشره هذه ابرز العناوين
الخارجيه السعوديه تعلن بدء محادثات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تستمر
عده ايام من اجل هدنه انسانيه
روسيا تشن حمله غارات وساعه على اوكرانيا
عشيه احتفالات يوم النصر في التاسع من
مايو
ترحيب لوصي وتحفظ امريكي على عوده مشوطه
لسوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
بعد هذا الفصل قصير نواصل من جديد مع
حضراتكم نشاط الصباح من العربيه ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات